alors bienvenue docteur EPEL bonsoir
madame Dussault
vous avez démissionné on va venir dans
un instant mais la description qui a été
faite par les infirmières la situation
du bloc opératoire vous confirmez la
situation mais écoutez la situation et
la même et la même partout partout dans
le réseau que ce soit en Estrée ou
ailleurs et les différents services en
Estrie ni font pas exceptions il manque
de personnel partout et on en subit les
conséquences souvent effectivement le
bloc opératoire les urgences les
hôpitaux les services de les services
aiguës sont au première ligne de ces de
ces congestions là le cancer arrive
alors absolument pas surpris de ce qui
se passera de ce qui se passe et qui se
passera au bloc opératoire tout à fait
c'est l'image du reste j'ai cru
comprendre je vous le dis de mémoire
quelles sont peut-être une vingtaine à
occuper à s'occuper du bloc opératoire
alors que normalement elle devrait trois
fois plus exactement
sur les gens qui restent c'est vrai au
bloc c'est vrai ailleurs la tarte va
préparé en moins de monde et puis
évidemment il y aura de la modulation de
service comme à chaque année on annonce
toujours une catastrophe pour le temps
des fêtes ensuite c'est la grippe
ensuite c'est l'été ensuite c'est
l'automne ensuite c'est l'autre temps
des fêtes c'est de crise en crise de
cellules de crise en cellule de crise on
ne fait que gérer en crise à l'année
longue et c'est ça vous comme
gestionnaire avec un de vos collègues
d'ailleurs vous avez dénoncé je pense
dans une lettre de cette lourde
bureaucratique
vous en pouviez plus comme gestionnaire
vous étiez le chef département de
médecine générale effectivement en fait
effectivement on est confronté à une
inertie qui est difficilement
descriptive dans l'appareil
administratif l'appareil bureaucratique
de nos établissements de santé est
extrêmement lourd de nombreuses
directions une hiérarchie un peu
particulière et une difficulté pour le
gestionnaire terrain que qu'il soit
gestionnaire non médical qu'il soit
médecin qui soit infirmière pour le
gestionnaire terrain de réellement
amener des pérenne des changements
significatifs qui répondent aux besoins
des gens qui permettent aux gens de
rester au travail qui permettent
d'offrir des services on se bute à des
une incapacité de changer de façon
significative les choses des choses qui
permettraient réellement d'amener des
services aux gens qu'est-ce que vous
auriez aimé changer vous et votre
collègue aussi que démissionner là je
sais pas si vous étiez concerté mais en
tout cas en fait on est plusieurs en
parallèle à être arrivé à la même
conclusion à peu près au même moment on
a vécu relativement les mêmes choses
chacun dans nos secteurs respectifs en
fait ce qui manque on pourrait donner
des exemples toute la soirée mais on
essaie beaucoup de faire du One Size
fitzer on essaie d'imposer une directive
muramure partout mais ça ne fonctionne
pas comme ça on veut ramener il faut
amener une agilité une originalité il
faut être il faut être innovant dans
notre façon de
solutionner les problèmes qui sont
devant nous et les structures ne nous
permettent pas ça c'est du top down bien
d'en haut ça descend ça peut même venir
du ministère par exemple en médecine
générale
je prends l'exemple par exemple de ce
qui s'est passé sur nos unités de soins
où on est effectivement confronté comme
plein d'autres à des à des pénuries de
personnels on a été confronté à des
fermetures de lit même si c'était pas
nécessairement la meilleure solution les
gens n'ont pas été consultés ça se
décide un peu en arrière-plan on leur
annonce les décisions à la dernière
minute on a de la difficulté à régler un
problème sur une unité spécifiquement
exemple des fermetures de lit exemple
par exemple de l'adaptation de de face à
la covid sur certaines unités qui
contiennent des personnes âgées qui
subissent par subir des conséquences des
règles qu'on essaie d'appliquer pour
prévenir la covid mur à mur
les fermetures de lit ont fait beaucoup
beaucoup de mal on essaie le plus
possible de d'amener de la saveur locale
dans les décisions mais quand les gens
qui connaissent le terrain sont pas
consultés les décisions qui arrivent qui
atterrissent souvent sont déconnectés
avez-vous vous êtes toujours médecin
vous pratiquez la médecine à l'hôpital
donc vous recevez des patients peut-être
à l'urgence je ne sais trop sur des
unités d'hospitalisation puis dans un
CLSC donc on est confronté effectivement
des patients la réponse qu'elle a été la
réaction chez vous on a entendu docteur
Tremblay là répondre
j'entends l'oreille c'est ce qui est
c'est ce qui c'est ce que je vois c'est
à dire une certaine oreille à nos à nos
recommandations à nos demandes
malheureusement les actions ne semblent
pas venir et restent pas la première
fois effectivement c'est sorti public
son récentes mais les à l'interne les
demandes ont été faits à plusieurs
occasions à plein de niveaux
hiérarchiques mais le changement
culturel que l'on doit amener dans
l'établissement il n'arrive pas alors on
continue à agir des gestionnaires
continuent à agir les mêmes notées les
médecins semblent encore vouloir
influencer dans la bonne direction mais
on ne semble pas lâcher du lo sur la
culture de contrôle excessive alors si
il y a la réforme du B qu'est-ce que
vous diriez au ministre qui était à côté
de vous là le ministre il faut qu'il
comprenne une chose la réforme du B va
changer va changer les structures va
changer des des de la gestion très très
haut dans l'organigramme ça va prendre
plein de temps au réseau de se
réorganiser puis retomber sur ses pattes
mais ce qu'il faut faire c'est de
laisser du Lux lâcher le contrôle lâcher
le contrôle et laisser des gestionnaires
agir sur le terrain prendre des
décisions innovantes docteur EPEL merci
beaucoup d'avoir accepté notre
invitation puis vous parler peut-être à
d'autres personnes de votre région qui
en ont jusque là merci beaucoup
pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI
[Musique]